it's 4:15 a.m. only 10 minutes now
before zero hour dawn is coming and my
heart is filled suddenly with bitterness
when I realized that the day may be my
last in a few minutes we attack two
minutes to go in which a thousand
thoughts mingle in my brain the thought
of the battlefield where I may lie in a
few moments weltering in blood the sweet
thought of our beloved land across the
sea and the thought of those I hold most
dear
yesterday I believed I can die with
something approaching indifference now I
am aware of an intense desire to live I
had made all preparation for the voyage
from which no traveler returns but now I
am unwilling to go for 25 a role as of
heavy Thunder sounds and the sky is
split by great sheets of flame I
scramble scramble over the parapet and
in one of the first in no man's land the
noise of the barrage fills our ears the
air pulsates and the earth rocks beneath
our feet I feel I am in an awful dream
now we are crossing ground so torn by
our barrage that no soil remains in
place we reach the enemy's front line
which has been blown to pieces
dead bodies lie half buried under the
fallen parapet and wounded arriving in
convulsions of pain a section the second
wave has come up a communication trench
and opened fire with the machine gun on
the Germans who must have come piling up
from a dugout when our barrage had
passed now they lie in a mass of gray
with blood splashed all around one lifts
a hand to his chest and falls in a
dugout entrance I shall never forget his
face a mask of tortured agony we reach a
line of railway whose rails and ties
have been hurled in all directions the
Sun is spreading golden rays over all
this carnage and destruction as though
mocking at the strange folly of man
[Music]
you